jt brubacher moments ago taking the
field here at pnc park i think his
second start
and strikeout one up one down
line to right and that'll fall for a hit
so contreras goes the other way a
one-ounce single and a man aboard for
the cubs
faces anthony rizzo who was hitless in
four trips last night
topped them up
there's
dustin fowler playing center field
for bryant hitting 259 with two home
runs
look at that
the only uh man
who reached a broken bat player
contreras couple of strikeouts pirates
come to bat bottom of the first and
trevor williams making his first start
at pnc park as a visitor frasier lifts
that out towards left center good jump
by half but he makes the catch so one
out here's evans basically you're
supposed to be on their bench key brian
hayes got hurt
second game of the year against the cubs
he's already got three home runs bounced
to short baez
two down here's brian reynolds coming
up and he beats the shift does reynolds
with a hard hit ball into right kevin
newman good contact guy they're short
stop guys
yeah they got him to swing and miss so a
hard guy to strike out and williams fans
newman and pitches out of the gym
four for seven in this series including
a game-winning home run on thursday
[Applause]
brushes at to center way back
into the batter's eye in center field
and baez on a pitch upstairs smokes it
his third of the year
and it is one to nothing look where the
mid is watch where the baseball ends up
so they're trying to go down and away
and the brubacher throws a floater right
over the heart of the plate
and immediately he knows his head drops
javi drops to bat
jason hayward now
and now he'll head back to the dugout
with a swinging strikeout
soul guard with a fly ball to center
fowler
so good work by a brubacher he does
[Applause]
give up the home run but comes right
back gets hayward and soul guard
fredericko leads off
and past the pitcher
and oh a little bobble
by baez
oh look at stallings
jacob stallings singles to left two
aboard with no one out the lefty hitter
the center fielder dustin fowler
toward left center field that'll get
down that'll bring polanco home to tie
it stallings heads to third fouler the
second owled at second base
and the bucks will challenge yeah very
close play at second base
it gets the heel of that front foot
very very close
it's hard to tell if the right toe
got to the base before the tag was made
on the right heel that didn't take long
he is safe the pirates challenge and the
call is overturned give fowler an rbi
double second and third infield in
brubacher who singled
his loan at bat
lined a right and a fair ball for
probanker
will score two and the pirates lead
three to one jt's first career rbis
major league baseball pitchers cannot
get jt brubacher out no he is that a
thousand banning a thousand and how
about that
let's see if trevor williams can escape
further damage you've got first base
open the dangerous colin moran at the
plate 2-2
swag and a miss struck him out
here's half now
line drive base hit right center field a
single for ian happ looked like
something off speed down low and he
golfs it
contreras
gets hit by that pitch
the third time he's been hit by a pitch
already this year well now rizzo up
there with two men on
to the right side ram they get one there
back to first and they throw it away and
it bangs off the front of the cubs
dugout into score is half rizzo to
second and he'll make it
he's six
a great job by drew baker they're gonna
challenge the set the slide by contreras
and they might have a
beef
okay he's outside can he reach oh man
that there's no way that's legal
out
double play and the pirates are out of
the inning
now stalling singled in the second
letter goes
ball four
and it's first and second dustin fowler
now doubled into the left center gap
and he's hit by the pitch to load the
bases barely graze that looked like that
left forearm how are we going to get the
jtb here how to get him out
and we'll tap her over the mound and
look at this
look at this out at second but brubacher
will pick up an rbi and the pirates lead
it four to one oh that's so guard tobias
but he just let it go through i think
sogard was trying to flip it through his
legs i'm not sure he made contact with
the glove or not but uh
yeah you can't get to
there two on two down the pitch frazier
hits a fly ball to left toward the line
long run jack peterson running over
makes a nice catch near the sidewall
he's okay good catch inning over within
it hubs trail four to one chris bryant
first up against jt brubacher and gets
hit in the left elbow
and now the home plate umpire greg
gibson
is calling the other umpires in
i'm not sure what this is all about
somebody's been tossed out of the game
gibson has just thrown somebody out of
the game
i think that they were bringing
everybody together and they were going
to warn both sides the coach who was
ejected mike borzelo associate pitching
catching and strategy coach baez now hit
a home run in the second
half
that's huge
strikes out baez with a curveball here's
eric sogarden
towards center field fowler coming in
and makes the catch and jtb
keeps them off the board
philip evans who's one for two
hard hit up the middle he has two more
hits today brian reynolds
one for two
and he bunts toward third
and he has a bunt hit
why not
smart play too odd nobody out walking a
strikeout for colin today
line to left center field for colin
moran
another hit another ribby
how about these bucks today
leading it five to one still nobody out
for kevin newman he had to hit his last
time
now the pitch swinging a ground ball
softly hit toward first rizzo will come
home and right into the slide he's out
reynolds two outs and here's jacob
stallings
swag and a miss and brothers able to get
stallings and that is that pirates
though
contreras has singled and has been hit
by a pitch
and oh smooth little play by kevin
newman
and contreras is really frustrated now
mr soft hands kevin newman bryant a hit
by a pitch as last time in that elbow
guard
to left
reynolds
and brian just missed it rizzo gonna tag
and try and advance and he will reynolds
looking for another assist long out for
bryant derrick shelton is out from the
pirates dugout he is satisfied with the
outing from his starting pitcher jt
brubaker pitched a nice ball game today
and we will see wilmer defo bad
and defo with a pinch hit drive to right
field defoe
d-i-f-o
clears the deck with a cannonball
[Applause]
first pirate homer for wilmer defoe and
gives the buckos
what seems to be now a commanding 7-1
lead look at it here oh that was
actually a slider thought he got a
fastball slider that just stayed up and
spun defoe gets all of it
newman the batter bouncer to short
backhanded by by his reverse pivot
throws to second they get one in the
throw to first not in time very nice
play by baez [ __ ] doing his thing
quickly into a throwing position and
slings it right on the money to duffy
good turn so newman runs well he's able
to beat the rap 7-1 pirates here in the
ninth two outs base is empty
and there's a ground ball to second
frazier on to first rays
the jolly roger the pirates
defeat the chicago cubs
and handily beat them in back-to-back
games
ho hum last couple of days